en esta ocasión también voy a trabajar
con la función y es igual a la raíz de x
y también la voy a girar pero en esta
ocasión no la voy a girar ni alrededor
del eje de las x ni alrededor del eje de
las 10 la voy a girar alrededor de otra
recta que recta me voy a tomar en esta
ocasión vamos a poner esta esta recta
que va a ser igual a 1 así que déjenme
dibujarla para que sepan de qué recta
estoy hablando esta va a ser una recta
de igual a 1 y lo que voy a hacer es
girar mi función que es igual a la raíz
de x alrededor de esta recta y con ello
voy a crear un sólido de revolución el
cual va a tener un cierto volumen que
voy a querer calcular en esta ocasión y
bueno entre qué valores no voy a querer
tomar este sólido de revolución voy a
suponer que me voy a tomar este valor
entre la intersección y x igual a 4 este
de aquí va a ser x igual a 4 y por lo
tanto lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es dibujar lo vamos a intentar
visualizar un poco qué es lo que está
pasando por lo tanto esta va a ser mi
base esta que estoy dibujando aquí y
aquí claramente se nota que el eje de
rotación es la recta y que igual
y también voy a dibujar la otra parte de
la parte de abajo y ahora voy a darle un
poco de volumen para que se vea mucho
más real es un estilo trofeo en esta
ocasión o algo parecido se dan cuenta
está su base y bueno ahora la pregunta
es cuál es el volumen de este sólido de
revolución que tengo aquí para obtenerlo
me voy a basar otra vez en el método de
los discos pero en esta ocasión voy a
hacer un método de los discos el cual va
a ser ligeramente distinto a lo que
hemos visto las veces anteriores
entonces lo primero que voy a hacer es
dibujar aquí mi disco entonces voy a
suponer que esta es la base de mi disco
la cara de mi disco la cara en moneda y
tiene también un cierto grosor que va a
ser este de aquí recuerden que lo que
quiero es que el grosor se haga lo más
pequeño posible para que al final
podamos construir la suma de todos los
discos en este intervalo entonces para
calcular yo el volumen de este disco lo
primero que necesito es calcular el área
de su base y para esto pues el área del
círculo por lo que necesitamos sacar el
área de este círculo que tenemos aquí y
bueno el área se saca multiplicando a pi
por el radio al cuadrado
entonces va a ser pi que multiplica el
radio pero en esta ocasión quién va a
ser el radio al cual vamos a elevar al
cuadrado bueno pues si te das cuenta el
radio es la distancia que hay entre la
función y es igual a la raíz de equis y
la función que igual a 1 es decir la
diferencia lo que me voy a tomar es la
diferencia entre la función y igual a la
raíz de x menos la función e igual a 1
es esta distancia que hay de aquí a
camps y con ello ya obtuve yo el radio
por lo tanto déjame escribirlo y que
multiplica a la raíz de x que es la
primera función entonces es la función
superior menos la función inferior ya
esto hay que quitarle la función
inferior que es igual a 1 o dicho de
otra manera la recta que es mi eje de
rotación y bueno ya con esto tengo el
área de esta circunferencia que yo tengo
aquí si yo lo que quiero es calcular el
volumen del sólido de revolución que les
llevo contando durante todo este vídeo a
pues a esta área que acabamos de sacar
tenemos que multiplicar la por el grosor
pero el grosor en este caso es de equis
y por lo tanto todo esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la diferencia del de x
por de x y después tomar la integral es
decir
la suma de todos los volúmenes de todos
los discos que tenemos aquí y desde
donde a donde pues primero que se carga
intersección es decir cuando x vale 1 e
igual a 1 es lo mismo que igual a la
raíz de x hasta donde hasta el valor que
habíamos dicho habíamos dicho que íbamos
a tomar el valor de x igual a 4 y hoy
estamos tomando valores en el eje de las
x
este es nuestro eje de las x entonces es
desde x igual a uno hasta x igual a 4 y
para no confundirnos vamos a poner más
grueso el eje de las x muy bien entonces
realmente lo que estoy haciendo es sacar
el sólido de revolución que me queda al
girar esta área alrededor de la recta
igual a uno son los mismos problemas por
lo tanto tengo esta integral desde uno
hasta x igual a 4 y que creen ya
solamente que resolver esta integral
para encontrar nuestro volumen del
sueldo de revolución que estamos
buscando y ya no está tan difícil así
que vamos a resolverlo el volumen es
igual a la integral de uno a uno de uno
a cuatro
depp y voy a sacar pi porque es una
constante entonces el valor de pime
queda fuera y adentro tengo el raíz de x
menos uno
al cuadrado lo cual es un binomio el
cuadrado perfecto también lo podemos ver
o lo podemos hacer como una
multiplicación de dos binomios es decir
la raíz de x menos 1 que multiplica a la
raíz de x menos uno entonces raíz de x
por reid de x x en raíz raíz de x menos
uno es menor raíz de x menos 1 por la
raíz de x es menor raíz de x también y
menos 1 por menos 1 me da 1 positivo
entonces tengo x y toda esta expresión
la podemos simplificar un poco me va a
quedar la integral de x menos dos veces
la raíz de x desde cuenta que menos la
raíz de x menos la raíz de x pues es dos
veces la raíz de x ya esto le sumamos 1
y todo esto hay que multiplicarlo por de
x ok y entonces vamos a encontrar esta
integral ya está muy sencillo a esto
esto es lo mismo que piqué multiplica y
ahora sí voy a buscar la santidad
derivadas dejemos el factor izado y
busquemos la derivada de quien primero
la derivada de x es la anti derivada que
más no sabemos si es x cuadrado entre 2
después la anti derivada de dos veces la
raíz de x bueno el 2 es constante se
queda fuera y cuál es el anti derivado
de la raíz
pues esto es lo mismo que poner x a la
un medio por lo tanto le sumamos un
medio me queda x a la tres medios y
dividido todo esto entre tres medios
también entonces esto hay que dividirlo
entre tres medios o dicho de otra manera
mejor o escribir de esta forma esto lo
mismo que dos que multiplica dos tercios
que es el inverso de tres medios que
multiplica a x elevado a la tres medios
ya tengo la primera anti derivada la
segunda anti derivada este era mi
constante que yo tenía aquí que
inclusive sería bueno probarlo si yo
bajo el 3 medio se cancela con el dos
tercios y le bajó uno al exponente y me
va a quedar un medio por lo tanto esta
expresión al derivar la me da la
expresión de arriba y es mi anti
derivada y después tengo que encuentra
el anti derivada de uno de x que es x y
todo esto evaluado de 1 a 4 de 1 a 4 muy
bien y entonces ahora voy a dejar el
[ __ ] de vía fuera y vamos a hacer la
evaluación lo primero que tengo que
hacer es la evaluación en el término de
arriba por lo tanto voy a sustituir en
lugar de x por 4 y me queda 4 elevado al
cuadrado menos 2 menos dos por dos
tercios es lo mismo que 4
entonces es menos cuatro tercios y
después me queda 4 elevado a la 3 medios
si yo le saco la raíz a 4 es lo mismo
que 2 y 2 elevado al cubo pues es 8 por
lo tanto aquí me queda esto que
multiplica 8 más 4 y ya con esto termine
la evaluación en el término de arriba
ahora vamos a fijarnos en el índice
inferior es decir me tengo que tomar la
diferencia de un medio y después tengo
menos 2 que multiplican a lo mejor de gm
para no hacerme bolas y no equivocarme
como siempre ponerlo con un paréntesis
es todo esto menos todo lo que está aquí
entonces ahora si uno elevado al
cuadrado entre 2 es un medio positivo
porque aquí está en medio el signo de
menos por lo tanto no me voy a complicar
la vida es el índice superior la
evaluación en el índice superior menos
de evaluación en el índice inferior por
lo tanto ahora lo que voy a hacer es
sustituir todo por 1 y me queda un medio
menos cuatro tercios dos por dos tercios
son cuatro tercios y uno a lo que sea
pues es 1 ya esto hay que sumarle uno y
ahora sí lo segundo que voy a hacer es
a simplificar un poco toda esta
expresión a hacer toda la talacha que
tengo encima 4 elevado al cuadrado entre
2 es lo mismo que 16 entre 2 que es 8
después nos queda cuatro tercios que
multiplica a 8 pues es lo mismo que 8
por 4 32 entre 3 es decir treinta y dos
tercios y después a esto tengo que sumar
cuatro y ahora sí voy a multiplicar por
menos menos un medio más cuatro tercios
y después menos uno menos por más uno es
lo mismo que menos uno y ahora voy a
simplificar todo esto si se dan cuenta
el mínimo común múltiplo entre 32 y 36
por lo tanto voy a sacar el mínimo común
múltiplo o dicho de otra manera el común
denominador y el común denominador es 6
y dice 6 entre unas 6 por 8 48 menos 6
entre 32 por 32 pues es 64 entonces
estoy tengo que quitar 64 6 entre 16 por
4 24 6 entre 2 estrés por un es menos 3
y después 6 entre 3 es 2 x 4 es 8
entonces a esto
y sumar 8 y después menos 1 es lo mismo
que menos 6 sextos entonces me queda
menos 6 y ahora pues ya me queda
solamente que hacer la operación de acá
arriba y dice 48 menos 64 pues es lo
mismo que 64 menos 48 que es 16 pero con
signo negativo entonces de estos dos me
queda 16 negativo ya esto hay que
sumarle 24 es decir 24 16
es lo mismo que 88 positivo y el 8
positivo hay que quitarle 3 lo cual me
da 5 y después 58 es 13 y 13 6 617 7
entonces todo esto me da de resultados 7
y sextos ya están multiplicando por fin
entonces 7 peas estos perfectos 7 pi
sextos es mi resultado voy a ver si no
me equivoqué 48 64 6 16 negativo más 24
es 8 8 y 8 16 menos seis es 10 ok sí
perfecto 7 pi sextos y bueno ya con esto
tengo por fin el volumen de éste
paraboloide peculiar